go
oh my god hey everyone it's me jasmine
and i'm joined today by a special guest
hey i'm murad we've chosen some of our
favorite snacks i've chosen american
snacks and i chose snacks that i grew up
eating as a palestinian after every
round we're going to see if we want to
keep the snack or swap them let's get
snacking my favorite thing to do time to
reveal our first snack ready let's go
three two one oh
oh my god i'm excited to try those i
love me some nuts
so i see you brought some cheetos flamin
hot cheetos lime baby i haven't been
eating a lot of american snacks lately
just because i'm trying to watch my
figure but yeah these will be new to me
i might be down to swap we'll see really
can you tell me what you brought today
so hospitality culture is really
important in the middle east basically
anytime you go to an arab or a middle
eastern person's house you're going to
see like a ton of food but specifically
like a lot of different kinds of mixed
nuts these are my personal favorite
they're really good they're sweet and
sour and pistachios are just always
awesome let me dig into mine ah nothing
like opening a fresh bag of hot cheetos
eh cheers
i don't know how i'm gonna be able to
swap with you my mouth is salivating
weirdly mine too
whenever i get the munchies these are
the first things i think of if you're
brave and you can open a pistachio with
just your mouth you could just like
throw the whole thing in your mouth you
ever suck on the shell that's what i
really want to do but i can't do it on
camera
i'll do it
shall we trade let's do it
yeah i'm not gonna lie because they're
pretty good
let me know what you think of you okay
cheers
mmm
wow i don't taste the sweetness it just
tastes like pistachios doused in lime i
think maybe the sweetness is on the
shelf
when you get a bag of them there's like
a whole like layer of powder at the
bottom and it's like all sugar
what's happening i did it with my mouth
nice
it's very good it's just hard to choose
you know what i don't like this keeper
swap thing i want both yeah this is hard
because i haven't had these in a long
time i kind of love those too much it's
like in your soul right yeah i feel like
i'd be betraying my culture if i didn't
i could eat these i could swap i'm gonna
keep this
on to snack two all right ready to do
this let's do it three two one oh my god
i have brought fruit by the foot a very
very iconic part of my childhood my mom
would put these in our lunch boxes i
just put them in my mouth and eat them
like all rolled out and just
i can show you what i do so i brought
you guys might know this as turkish
delight but i grew up calling this
halcum they're super sweet usually rose
water flavored and it's coated in like
powdered sugar this is a foot long fruit
gummy it's actually longer than a foot
so i would roll it out all the way and
then i would take this part off and i
just like walk around
imagine a small jasmine walking around
at school
and then sometimes you stand up and then
you count down and see who can eat the
fastest you wanna do it let's do it and
i noticed it's gelatin free so my family
if you guys are seeing this there's no
pork on this
i bet they made the paper edible too
because i'm sure people are eating the
paper it's not edible
so you can put up to like a tongue's
length in your mouth and that's it three
two
one
go
oh my god
how the heck did you do that
really hard vaguely fruity so tasty
shall we try these let's do it to me
these are like old lady desserts because
one of my aunts houses they'd usually
have a plate of these i hated these for
a really long time but these are pretty
good i'm not gonna lie i love it yeah i
actually also grew up eating turkish
delights
and one time our family watched the lion
the witch and the wardrobe yeah and
that's when our family obsession with
turkish delights came about you can't
really avoid getting the sugar all over
yourself it's like a more delicate
elevated pretentious dessert in
comparison to fruit roll-ups i will
actually swap these because they're good
and i'm nostalgic but that was fun i did
like that fruit roll-up experience all
right so then how about you take these i
will actually swap with you because i
love them and with the rest of these why
don't you practice and we can do a
rematch next time let's do it on to the
next one three two one oh
i have brought ritz toasted chips sour
cream and onion flavored have you had
these no i've actually never had these
they will blow your mind my roommate
brought them home one day a couple years
ago and she was like do you want some i
was like sure and i was like
i could literally see my pupils like
dilate and ever since i've been addicted
what did you bring i brought malmo these
are date cookies i wish i was able to
bring fresh ones like the ones that my
mom makes because they're 10 000 times
better but these will do i know a lot of
people don't like dried fruits but dates
are actually surprisingly good as a
cookie filling they're really soft and
so soft that they're like kind of
smushed sometimes but
oh my gosh still really good they're
very crumbly and dry they're dry in a
way that complements like tea thank you
so much i feel like i've got the golden
ticket
it's so pretty
cheers
mmm it's like a shortbread cookie yeah
actually yeah this is very good
traditionally they're made out of farina
which is more crumbly but these will do
in a pinch
any idea of like ritz that you had on
your mind throw that out because this is
a whole other level oh so good they look
so fancy
oh my god i'm not even joking these are
so freaking good so good also best
flavors sour cream and onion
regular roots look manufactured the
flavor is like more intense it just
feels more like artisanal yeah almost
like a flattened breadstick for this one
i'm gonna have to keep this one oh i was
going to swap it but only because my mom
makes better mahmud
and these would be a good addition to my
pantry so you are i want to swap i'll
share with you yeah okay
next step ready
let's go three two one
oh
so colorful
these are jordan almonds they're
basically just like candy coated almonds
and for some reason i really associate
these with like weddings i feel like a
lot of wedding goodie bags had these
growing up that would be like the
highlight of a wedding for me and i see
you've also brought something very
colorful the ever so loved sour patch
kids when i think sour patch kids i
think of movies this is like the go-to
that we would get at the movie theaters
and i say that lightly it was more like
i went to target first put in my purse
and then went to the movies and then ate
them during the movies all right
family size baby i don't have a favorite
but for some reason i always go for the
blue are they all the same flavor
because i've actually really wondered
about it i don't i think this one's blue
raspberry orange this is either green
apple or watermelon and yellow is lemon
cheers
gummies are my favorite candies that's
so good i love when it sticks to your
teeth i don't think i like that so these
are all the same flavors unfortunately
yes tradesies you know i will say the
colors of these make me feel so relaxed
cheers
i love candy shell i'm not gonna lie
when you said they were almonds i was
like
i don't really like almonds i really
only taste the hard shell candy which
makes me like them more really good so
unlike the almonds i feel like these are
gonna stress me out
they're pretty good i think you can't
eat too many you definitely can't go
crazy with sour patch kids i've never
experienced anything he's talking about
family size should say jasmine size i'm
definitely keeping mine i have to say
i'm keeping mine too yeah okay you can
take it
but i do love these okay they're really
good that was really fun murad thank you
for bringing all those snacks i love
trying some new foods yeah thanks for
bringing a bunch of foods that i totally
forgot i loved and now you have some
homework work on that fruit by the foot
technique and we'll do a rematch okay
we'll see who wins next time because i
think i got it until next time bye
you